oh he's going off yeah ten the ten top
one
sorry if you guys don't sponsor no but
it's a little white no yelp is
whack here's my thing with yelp and all
that stuff it's like have you ever left
a yelp review no
i didn't i did i felt white that day
yeah but but you only did that one day
you felt white or asian
there was only people leaving i was like
yeah because i had well no i didn't i
didn't feel whiter
i'm not gonna like what a person that
leaves a yelp review like
i don't [ __ ] with i don't know anything
yeah i don't yeah i don't know you i
don't know you everyone's perception is
different it's like have you ever left a
youtube comment no
never why so why the [ __ ] would i invest
in it yeah you left
youtube comments what are you doing what
are you g i got caught up i bet he got
caught up today i bet you got on youtube
comments after the last episode and
you're like brennan's weak man they
should have more
every comment we all keep saying it's
brilliant like this guy on the side
he's killing it they figured it out it
was you you're too near me not to hear
me
i'm saying yeah shut up with them dumb
sayings too
you need to make that shirt you tune in
here bro he hit me with something he was
like yo uh
yo i see you in brittany y'all got that
little y'all got some ocean in your
emotion but i i hear you
but don't sip that podcast potion
i was like wait is this the pink drink
he was like yeah that pink drinking pink
he he comes off this is off the top of
the bro everything he says
i can't have a conversation with him i
love him he was like that juice would
give you the audience and you the
caboose i was like
i hung up he was like is that me and you
i said i look up what you want
i'll tell brittany i need him he's
fantastic i swear you're me
louisiana batman really yeah oh hell
yeah they call him city slicker south
the mouth for the south
dance yeah i don't like him man yeah
everything he said you can't have a
conversation with him dawg everything's
right
everything he says is just rhymes i'm
like what's the soft one he says
he was like bro look keep your head up
don't get lost in the sauce young buck i
said wait
wait is it barbecue what what sauce are
you talking about see your
your mind is wicked your mind is wicked
i love it bro hell yeah he watched the
episode he was like i see it brother i
see you brother what's his name
his name is uh uncle berry that's dope
cat you have a gun
no i don't your sister have a gun huh
your sister have a gun no why would we
have guns why would we need
you know what i got that i don't know
the world's on fire what type of life do
you think i'm living it is
hopefully a safe one you know what i
have that they told me i can't have a
grenade a
dream no a dream chuck i have nunchucks
illegal it's so dumb it's so dumb i know
you can have a gun but you can't have
that you gotta have life i know how to
use them let's see if they're still
illegal
you gotta have a license uh-huh well i
don't have them anymore
no i'm so serious what is weird yeah
what what is that about
numchucks yep illegal to possess in
california except in martial arts
classes
yeah that's it's so dumb some of these
rules are so dumb outright illegal in
new york arizona and
massachusetts wow i got him in texas
for my buddy i mean they're just like a
display thing i don't know
you could just make them so easily with
like broomstick so
it's it's fun using them on things yeah
how do you get the timing
uh i don't know i just youtube i watch
youtube videos
i learned the weirdest [ __ ] dude and i
just get like good at it i just know how
to use it what else you got jen
john claude van damme jean-claude this
is weird someone said this to me um i'll
find his name in a bit but i'll play it
for you first
he's doing a music video yeah it's
trippy though check this out
[Music]
this is fantastic i respect you know
what i'm going to do
i'm going to do this in dallas i'm going
to post it on saturday
i'm going to do this exact same thing
you have purple pants
we're cool pants figure it out
i'm going to do this
inside of it you're not going to
recreate this video i'm not going to
recreate
it she's not going to rock side to side
like you can miss me at the beach
what was that what was the purpose i was
like guaranteed martin can edit me into
it
you can edit all this for me wow that
looks fantastic yeah you write this song
no he didn't i have i i doubt he did
sad story yeah he's like flying private
doing all these doing all this blow
oh he was in the blow oh yeah you don't
become jean-claude van damme do the
splits every goddamn day
you got it you need a little bit of
little blow i don't have much more
favorite dude yeah
i love bloodsport you were the steven
seagal guy or john claude van damme i
was joking
it was hardcore
you're thinking mel gibson also get the
[ __ ] out
god dawg wow yeah wait stephen seagull's
that
thick mexican who knew kung fu he's
missing yes i'm serious
no he's not he's a white guy but he also
has citizenship in russia
well put a push bro john claude i'm
sorry steven
is a giant mexican who fooled everyone
thinking he's asian what no
i made up the mexican part but he's not
nothing
chuck norris is mexican yes no chuck
norris is not mexican yeah his real name
is carlos
really yeah oh he has a russian citizen
yeah he's white no no he loves russia
anyone goes to russia apparently anybody
that goes to russia
looks mexican cigar was born in lansing
michigan all right wait really chuck
norris is uh
stephen cigar baby yeah no he was
thinking the truck wait chuck norris is
not mexican
his name is carlos his real name really
i think he's mexican wait hold on
tomorrow
stop it stop it now
oh never mind native american oh yes i'm
sticking with stevenson
i used to
hey oh really name the biggest japanese
guy you know there's no japanese guys
with guts and
six six i don't i don't i'm not no i'm
not in them streets
i don't know i'm not over there i'm not
hey when you do stand up on flyers do
they put your boxing picture ever
nah they used to do that to me they did
do they really put like a ufc picture
like
would why why are you in clubs now they
know like if you do that yeah
yeah yeah 100 percent zero maybe zero
maybe like someone putting up a cheer
picture of me isn't that [ __ ] up yeah
like your pals here in your
louisville like this
when i first started clubs used to be
like ufc fighter i'm like
you that's not gonna no one's buying a
ticket if they see ufc fighter on the
top
no anyone who knows me already knows i
did that that's my past
but any walk by traffic and i'm like ah
[ __ ] that i'm not going to this yeah
yeah whatever
damn you strive me nuts man it took me
forever to get over that hump
forever yeah forever yeah i can only
imagine
what you had to go through like bro
because you didn't want to like be get
mad and fight them because you can beat
them up and you're just playing it to
the flyer
but i'm saying yeah you can just like
brought my comic dude i'm gonna stand up
you don't have urges to fight like i
have urges to cheer you
how like on stage you do you know you do
flips you do
you flip sometimes i think about
competing again see if i still got it
just
really got it no never never never bring
it we do wrestling fridays
i know you're getting you wrestle
fridays yeah oh in the group
what went out what video you and me
wrestling
and i couldn't you were tapping the
ground not me no he's tapping and
tapping himself
norbert
so stupid now ladies and gentlemen
that's such a great
i mean i didn't know fighting obviously
but i was just like what's up brennan
yeah you're scrappy though leadership
yeah he said i was strong he was strong
strong she's happy
what'd you say about me scrappy
scrappy i'll take it i'll tell you just
a different language
louis but terrible club i was out there
and it was just chaos because they
they haven't had a lot of comics come
through there and joey diaz told me not
to go there he's like they're outrageous
dude i'm telling you don't go there
i'm like whatever joey you've only been
standing for 30 years
i still went out there dog
nightmare with like the crowd like
straight up like
talking like loud like conversations
really yeah and i was like god damn the
security they're like oh we ain't
working tonight you got this man
[ __ ] you're gonna [ __ ] him up like dude
i'm not here for that bro
nobody's fighting i need you guys just
to control the room
they literally were just all in the back
on their cell phones